il ya deux sortes d'homosexuels ya
d'abord ceux qui sont malades puis ceux
qui font ça pour de l'argent alors que
déjà des choses différentes je considère
mal-être des fous comme le fou qui
s'entame ex ante vous les comprenez vous
les amis clément oui j'ai des amis qui
sont comme ça comment jugez vous les
hommes qui aiment les hommes c'est pas
normal c'est un risque quoi par éthique
dans ma maison il y en a ça vous gêne je
ne sais pas si c'est vrai je me pose la
question si c'est exact
vous parlez aussi bien députés une femme
comme député monde
vous pensez que tous les [__] sont des
[__] se prostituent
pourquoi il le ferait alors tu vois là
moi je peux me regarder pour enfin et ça
leur plaît qu'est ce que vous pensez des
pdg pas vous aimez pas pourquoi j'ai pas
je trouve que c'est laid
je sais pas j'ai pas le jour du carnaval
coût
l'égalité ce sont les mêmes droits pour
tous quel que soit son sexe
l'orientation c'est le droit de pouvoir
se marier d'adopter pour les coûts qui
en décide ainsi
c'est l'engagement 31 de la campagne
présidentielle de françois hollande est
l'une des priorités du début de son
quinquennat
après les pays bas la belgique l'espagne
ou encore le danemark la france s'empare
du mariage homosexuel une réforme
emblématique pour la gauche mais rejetée
par une majorité de la droite
le sénat a choisi jean-pierre michel
comme rapporteur du texte il ya 13 ans
est élue socialiste a déjà été le
rapporteur de la loi sur le pacs
cet ancien magistrat s'est toujours
battu pour les droits des homosexuels
j'ai en moi une espèce de passion pour
l'égalité alors je sais bien que
l'égalité n'est pas n'est pas naturel
que giuly sont pas tous égaux
parce que nous ne laissons pas de la
même manière parce que nous avons des
familles qui nous permettent de faire
plus d'études nous sommes élevés dans
des milieux différents
donc nous ne sont pas égaux c'est vrai
mais je pense que le rôle du législateur
et notamment que c'est le rôle des
socialistes de prendre toutes les
mesures possibles pour réduire
l'inégalité et pour réduire dans la rue
la contestation prend forme
le collectif la manif pour tous trouvant
frigide barjot l'égérie médiatique qui
lui faisait défaut
cet humoriste atypique chroniqueuse
mondaine et fervente catholique devient
la porte parole des opposants au texte
13 janvier 2013 julien et cécile
manifeste pour la première fois de leur
vie pour d'enfer comme on l'avait fait
déjà
on traverse
faut se trouver un nouveau traverser
membre d'alliance vite à une association
fondée par christine boutin contre
l'avortement et l'euthanasie
ils sont opposés au projet du
gouvernement cécile est conseillère
municipale à fontenay le fleury dans les
yvelines ce qui la gêne dans ce projet
de loi c'est l'adoption par les couples
homosexuels ou les leur donner un papa
et maman va leur donner deux papas ou
deux mamans et ça me semble pas être
être le bien profond de l'enfant qui a
besoin de s'identifier à un père ou une
mère
ce jour là le champ de mars est envahi
de drapeaux roses et bleus une bataille
des chiffres va opposer les anti mariage
homosexuel au gouvernement entre 340
milles selon la préfecture de police et
800 mille manifestants selon les
organisateurs vont être comptabilisés
face à cette opposition qui s'exprime de
plus en plus fort les partisans du
projet de loi descendre dans la rue à
leur tour au delà du mariage gay c'est
bien de france qui vont apparaître et de
conception de la famille qui vont
s'affronter pour tous les enfants
d'aller c'est la première fois qu'on
manifeste parce qu'on a été choqués de
voir kaka joue avec autant de personnes
dans les rues qui manifestaient contre
notre liberté notre on les laisse
choisir leur orientation sexuelle leur
choix de vie leurs familles
à l'assemblée nationale les députés ont
commencé l'examen du texte l'opposition
entend créer le débat dans l'hémicycle
cinq mille amendements sont déposées le
projet de loi prévoit le mariage et
l'adoption pour les couples homosexuels
les il n'est pas question d'autoriser la
procréation médicalement assistée ou la
gestation pour autrui
c'est pourtant le chiffon rouge que va
agiter la droite pendant les cent dix
heures de discussions dans l'aîné
s'inscrit à l'article et vous me
fournissait l'occasion de réaffirmer
réaffirmé formellement ici que ce
gouvernement s'est déjà prononcée et
confirme qu'il est absolument opposé à
la gpa et qu'il ne l'ouvrira par des
débats vont révéler l'autorité et la
détermination de christiane taubira
après des jours et des nuits passées
dans l'hémicycle
merci à tous pour ses jours et ses nuits
passées ensemble pour c'est pour ces
sourires pour ses reer pour ces
confrontations aussi conviction contre
conviction ce projet de loi nous a
conduits à penser autrui à consentir à
l'altérité pensée autrui disait emmanuel
levinas relève de l'irréductible
inquiétude pour l'autre c'est ce que
nous avons fait le long de ce débat
après l'assemblée nationale c'est au
tour du sénat d'être saisi le sénat a
choisi de prendre son temps et
d'entendre toutes les opinions sur ce
texte
quarante audition menée par jean pierre
michel et jean pierre sueur
le président de la commission des lois
des auditions qui vont permettre aux
sénateurs de se faire leur propre
opinion
la plupart des sénateurs ont une
position très arrêtées qui est
dépendante de l'orientation de leur
parti politique
bon voilà mais quand on les interroge un
peu plus pour certains ça me paraît
beaucoup plus nuancé et donc pense que
avec des informations comme ça reconnaît
bière ou encore aujourd'hui ou demain où
il ira peut-être que certains sénateurs
pourraient soit d'un côté ou de l'autre
ce surtout je parle sur toi ceux qui
seront contre par principe se détacher
de son compte propre et zip est arrivé à
une abstention
on devrait être plus positif les
anthropologues sociologues psychiatres
religieux juriste et membre de la
société civile vont se succéder à la
tribune pendant plusieurs semaines très
vite il apparaît que ce n'est pas tant
le mariage qui fait débat mais plutôt la
question de l'adoption par des couples
homosexuels
tron m'écouter fait très plaisir
la première trouver le sénat va avoir un
rôle très particulier dans la capacité
qu'il aura à démêler cette caste ces
malentendus sur la filiation
on comprend mieux après après deux trois
mois de débats qu'on ne les comprenaient
au début donc j'attends beaucoup du
sénat est une assemblée dont je sais
depuis longtemps que c'est un endroit où
on débat les questions vraiment au fond
alors pour montrer à quel point cette
question fait débat
je citerai parmi les très nombreux les
très nombreuses personnes que j'aurais
pu citer un organisme qui est tout à
fait capital l'union nationale des
associations familiales qui dans un
document qu'elle a rendues publiques en
octobre indique ceci ouvrir l'ensemble
de l'adoption aux couples de même sexe
pose en particulier la question de
l'adoption plénière alors qu'un enfant
ne peut naître que d'un homme et d'une
femme
l'accès éventuel à l'adoption plénière
remettrait juridiquement en cause cette
réalité laissant croire qu'il est
possible de naître de deux personnes de
même sexe
j'ai cité ce texte pour montrer et
énoncer désigner un malentendu car bien
entendu personne parmi les défenseurs du
projet n'imagine de laisser croire qu'un
enfant peut naître de deux femmes ou
deux hommes et qu'il n'est pas question
à travers l'adoption plénière de
remettront juridiquement en cause cette
réalité chez les pédopsychiatres
l'adoption par des couples de même sexe
fait débat un enfant peut-il être élevé
par deux parents de même sexe
les avis divergent faut savoir que pour
un enfant ça veut strictement rien dire
un parent de même sexe deuxièmement pour
un enfant un père qui n'engendre pas une
mère qui n'engendre pas soit d'un point
de vue réelle soit d'un point de vue
symbolique comme on l'a vu dans
l'adoption ou la mp ça ne peut pas
fonctionner parce qu'un enfant ne peut
pas se dire issus de deux hommes ou deux
femmes
vous parlez de l'absolue nécessité
d'avoir un père et une mère et ça me
surprendre par la psychanalyse parce qu'
est-ce que c'est pas le plus important
d'avoir une fonction paternelle et une
fonction maternelle qui n'est pas
forcément assumée par quelqu'un du sexe
masculin pour la fonction paternelle et
pour un enfant et ainsi de suite enfin
moi je je suis un père qui fait beaucoup
de fonction maternelle
comment dire le paternel de la femme ne
sera jamais le même que le paternel de
l'homme le maternelle de l'homme ne sera
jamais le même que le maternel de la
femme c'est à dire que au delà de cette
fonction il ya quelque chose qui dépasse
ces fonctions là qui est l'être propre
du père et l'autre propre de la mer et
là on a vu que l'enfant différent si
cela tout simplement parce que oui un
père ne sera jamais une mère comme les
autres et que et que cela dépasse
l'histoire de la fonction le fait de
descendre les poubelles et faire la
vaisselle cela n'a rien à voir
il y à des situations concrètes
effectivement donc la situation concrète
c est ce qu il est possible est pensable
que dans notre société
un enfant qui soit élevée par qui que ce
soit n'est pas référence aux deux sexes
qui existent dans la société ça il me
semble que tenir un tel discours et dire
non il n'aurait pas la référence c'est
absolument absurde
est ce que on considère que cette
référence aux deux sexes est ce qu'elle
doit être dans le cadre de la famille
nucléaire
ou alors est ce qu'elle peut être de
façon plus élargie c'est ça la question
pragmatique qu'il faut se poser une
famille nucléaire ou une famille peut se
concevoir de façon tout à fait élargi
combien d'entre nous ici on une idée de
leur famille qui ne se résume pas
uniquement à leur père à leur mère rêve
chez les juristes le débat est aussi
animée certains pensent que la loire met
en cause le droit de la filiation est la
base même du droit civil
d'autres pensent au contraire que la loi
doit suivre les évolutions de la société
la question que se joue ici c'est la
question des liens de droit et plus
particulier les dalles familiaux qui
sont fondés sur deux rapports de
rapports qui sont le rapport de
l'alliance qui repose sur le mariage et
la filiation
c'est à dire le rapport biologique ce
que je voulais dire c'est que ce lien de
la filiation et du mariage ils sont 1
détachable au départ donc ici on a met
en avant le lien biologique la vérité
biologique et vous accorder le mariage
aux couples homosexuels pour des
filiations qui seront forcément fictive
puisqu'il ne procréent pas entre eux
alors bouleversé à ce point tout le
droit de la filiation
parce que vous accordez le mariage à des
couples homosexuels qui n'entendent
quand même pas une majorité de français
je pense que c'est extrêmement grave et
au moins si vous le faites prenez le
temps et réfléchissent et en même temps
vous pouvez pas dissocier et dire on
verra plus tard ce qu'on a mis sous le
tapis
on le réduire à ça franchement je suis
venu vous dire ne faites pas ça c'est
trop grave
j'appelais sentiment que c'est développe
aujourd'hui une dimension plus de type
biologique
la revendication de l'accès aux origines
la place du des géniteurs ont renvoyé je
pense qu'il ya aujourd'hui un discours
qui tend plutôt à dire on est allé trop
loin dans la dimension volontaires
volontariste et la filiation dont
revenant quand même à une dimension
quelque peu biologique dont j'essaye de
démontrer le contraire et je pense qu'il
n'y a pas des liens plus forts et des
liens plus stable est pour moi des liens
plus sûr en tant que juriste des liens
d'engagement des responsabilités
qu'elles aient lien qui part dé la
volonté et non pas d'une imposition de
type biologique
je trouve que l'évolution est
souhaitable puisque si on fait rentrer
d'un institution dans la loi des gens
qui n'étaient pas originellement dans la
loi les juifs où est passée marié les
protestants pourrait passer marié les
femmes étaient soumises aux hommes les
enfants nés hors mariage n'avait pas
droit
donc tout l'histoire du mariage
l'histoire d'un élargissement d'une
institution qui a inclus qui n'était pas
une institution exclusive sur le plan du
droit
je trouve que l'on est en train de
bouleverser le droit de la filiation
sans vraiment le dire est qu'on va faire
une impasse juridique est d'ailleurs
beaucoup de spécialistes du droit civil
vous avez entendu peu de spécialistes du
droit civil qui était favorable à ce
texte tel qu'il est parce qu il a été
improvisée dès l'instant où on touche au
code civil j'aime bien placé pour le
savoir parce qu'à l'époque du pacs était
pareil on voit que tout tout ce qui en
fait une copie vie tout ce qui parle du
code civil les magistrats les mettra de
la chancellerie sont absolument
bouleversés voilà qu'après il faut bien
qu'ils s'y fassent et qu'ils ont fait
une nouvelle règle
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui nous recevons
l'ensemble des représentants des cultes
depuis deux heures de l'après midi 14h
jusqu'à fat aux juristes succèdent les
représentants des grandes religions qui
sont majoritairement contre le projet de
loi
le grand rabbin de france gilles
bernheim a écrit un texte qui a marqué
les esprits contre le projet de loi
je suis un homme de la bible comme peut
l'être le chrétien
le musulman est aussi mais de manière
différente puisque le livre n'est pas
écrit pour lui la bible
lorsqu'elle interdit formellement
l'homosexualité et notament expressément
le mot sécurité masculines et féminines
elle n'en parle pas mais ça c'est un
autre sujet comment est ce que je me
comporte devant vous avec ce texte
évidemment avec un tel texte
si vous demandez aux bibliste juifs ou
chrétiens
mais est ce que tu es pour est ce que tu
es contre le mariage des homosexuels
qu'est ce qu'ils voulaient qu'il amorce
comme réflexion l'homosexualité étant
strictement interdite dans la bible il
va vous n'imaginez pas un instant qu'il
va vous dire mais le mariage des
homosexuels
non seulement je l'autorisent mais je
vais lui donner un cadre juridique
je dirais qu'à la question est
anachronique
la première remarque je voudrais faire
c'est ce une question qui peut paraître
un peu byzantine mais qui ne l'est pas
c'est la question de savoir si la
différence sexuelle est une inégalité la
différence sexuelle n'est pas une
inégalité qu'il ya dans là dedans
l'existence humaine
il ya des données de fait les
différences de fait qui ne donne pas un
droit juridique à devenir comme les
autres c'est le mariage n'est pas un
bien comme un public qu'on peut
distribuer comme des sucettes à la
sortie de l'école donc ça n'est pas
c'est pas faire injustice ou injure que
de dire que le mariage a une fonction à
une finalité propre dans la société qui
est de structurer d'organiser la
transmission entre les générations et
l'éducation des enfants y croyons les
chrétiens on ne faisait pas un besoin
d'accueil en un devoir d'accueillir
toutes les personnes dont pas les
rejeter
en dehors de la sphère en fait ce qui se
fait aujourd'hui est donc vraiment je ne
comprends pas à quoi ça me faisait me
laisse complètement pantois en plus je
veux être un peu méchant je dirais que
rien n'allait nulle engine permet à ce
qu'il dit rien et surtout et surtout pas
ce qu'on appelle la sainte famille dans
le père et adoptifs
comme chacun sait dans la mère enfant
tel accent vierge à quels moyens
mais ma serre est pour l'interroger
entre les auditions d'experts
psychiatres ou de juriste jean pierre
michel auditionnent ce couple de
retraités après avoir lu leur témoignage
dans un journal annick et rené était
producteur de lait dans la région
nantaise
il y a vingt ans ils ont découvert
l'homosexualité de terry leur petite
dernière
ils ont fait depuis un long cheminement
avant de l'accepter
on est en couple et donc la région la 3e
et la 4e terry est homosexuel et l'a36 a
fait pratiquement vingt ans que
qu'on a découvert son nouveau sexualité
et puis avec nîmes on y connait service
du tout je croyais que c'était un choix
pervers c'est pas par ignorance sur lui
je crois pas j'étais pas mon fort je
crois pas mais moi j'en étais à ce stade
alors déjà
on voit un
mais je me disais mon enfant est pas
terrible n'est pas comme ce qu'on voit à
la télé là non c'est pas possible
oui parce que dans quelques années très
dur avec elle quand même eu une année
particulièrement ou vraiment on se
demandait le matin comment on allait la
retrouver ainsi sur le besoin de plus
que le vieux oui oui oui mais ça n'a pas
suffi non plus je crois que vraiment
l'acceptation le regard des autres est
très dur très dur
elle nous avait large qu il a été
retrouvé un courrier comme quoi m'étais
fait un séjour commence en possession
elle arrêtée elle a été récupérée juste
à temps mais veut briller jusqu'au cet
effet
homosexuel et vivent très bien heureux
ont fait parents de l'enfant mot
sexuelle est bien heureux pareils
ce qui les prix négatif pour les uns
comme pour les autres c'est le regard
des autres cette inquiétude
sinon on est bien
et le regard des autres est parfois
difficile à supporter deux mois après
leur audition au sénat
annick et rené rendent visite à leur
fille terry et à sa compagne bea près de
toulouse au lendemain d'une
manifestation des opposants ils sont
inquiets
chez la famille morantin le doute
commence à s'installer ici le texte ne
passait pas effectivement une flèche
tous comme ça la fin tous poussé aussi
fort ils viennent avec les enfants
poussent des barricades en feu
c'est un peu excessif pour un projet qui
est pas une question de vie - bonjour sa
fait impressionnant quand même mais bon
j'espère club
j'espère que le gouvernement va lâcher
moi ça m'inquiète beaucoup je m'inquiète
beaucoup je me dis qu'il tient pas à pas
grand chose en fait
une société qui loue king qui autorise
des choses et qui nous qui avance et une
société qui régresse kung fu
pour terry les débats autour du projet
de loi font ressurgir les fantômes du
passé est complètement renfermée
j'arrivais pas à leur dire ça j'étais
puis même j'ai été un petit peu entre
guillemets conditionné dans cette
religion qui est catholicisme avec le
avec l'église et pour moi c'était pas
compatibles du tout et je me demandais
où est ce que j'allais aller quand je
mourrai que je ne pourrais pas être
reconnu qu'on perd quand on est comme
étant une personne à part entière
je me suis je me suis enfermé dans ma
bulle romont monde
ma mère elle m'a dit parce que j'étais
effondrée 1 j'étais vraiment effondré
j'en ai pas l'agepi je savais pas
quels allaient être ses regrets sa
réaction j'avais vraiment peur pour ma
vie soit pas pire reste toujours fier de
ce que tu es de toi il m'a laissé un
écailler pour pouvoir exprimer tout mon
cheminement finalement tout ce que
j'avais sur le coeur et je crois que
c'est une vingtaine de pages de
l'écrivain prix d'un seul parce que
j'avais j'en avais beaucoup sur le coeur
à lire et donc il leur est donnée le
cahier juste après pour qu'ils puissent
lire et puis je le lis souvent c'est moi
le
mais tous les parents n'acceptent pas
toujours l'homosexualité de leur enfant
l'association le refuge à paris héberge
des jeunes rejetés par leur famille à
cause de leur homosexualité
pour le rapporteur du texte au sénat ce
projet de loi a aussi pour but de faire
reculer l'homophobie
moi j'ai 18 ans je suis hébergé depuis
trois semaines je suis en contact avec
eux refusent depuis quatre mois avec les
parents ça se passait mal depuis un an
et demi j'ai été placé au foyer g est à
la rue
chez des amis et ses talents ici le
problème si on nous insulte et c'était
juste ça c'était il n'accepte pas le
massacre était en fait ils vont ceux qui
acceptent mais en fait quand ils
voyaient l'homosexualité c'est non c'est
d une maladie moi je soutiens que quand
on y a des citoyens les d'avoir les
mêmes droits que les autres citoyens
c'est pas normal en france à tous les
citoyens sont égaux devant la télé qui
font tous sont là parce qu'ils ont fait
l'objet d'un rejet familial et je pense
que ce qu'il faut dire faut appeler la
responsabilité des parents et je crois
que quelles que puissent être les
d'exception qu'on peut avoir qu'un de
vos enfants soient homosexuels je peux
le comprendre je pense pas qu'il faut
jeter les jeunes
je suis au sénat jean-pierre michel
retrouve le député erwann binet
rapporteur de la loi à l'assemblée
nationale
objectif examiner le texte dans le
détail afin de pointer du doigt les
améliorations que le sénat pourrait
apporter par rapport à la version de
l'assemblée nationale après avoir
examiné le texte en détail il apparaît
et avoir entendu un certain nombre
d'auditions
il apparaît que le sénat devra apporter
un certain nombre d'amendements
j'aime bien ce moment parce que du coup
en scène sont de passage le rôle est
lourd on confie au sénat le travail
qu'il faut faire l'assemblée mais en
même temps avec la volonté qui est la
mienne de défendre un peu les amants à
que j'ai déposée ou auxquels je la
commission a donné un avis favorable
et puis peut-être de discuter sur
quelques points techniques qui ont été
révélés assez tardivement ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que le débat à l'assemblée a
été quand même très très vif très très
dur et qu' il ya eu de forme
d'improvisation en séance qui est
d'ailleurs le gouvernement lui même dit
que certaines
chose qu'ils ont été adoptés mérite
d'être mieux dû creuser le rapporteur du
texte au sénat souhaite modifier la
version de l'assemblée nationale soit
des points juridiques à la marge
me cher collègue nous allons ouvrir
notre cette séance je vous remercie
d'être venus très nombreux
signe de l'intérêt qui est le vôtre pour
le texte sur le mariage pour tous
mais ce qui cristallise le plus les
tensions chez les sénateurs alors qu'ils
interrogent la ministre sur son projet
de loi
c'est la question de la filiation et de
la pma alors merci madame benbassa
monsieur lecerf questions portent
effectivement également sur la pma et la
gpa qui sont un peu si vous voulez ce qu
était le resto rennes entre 71 et 1914
c'est à dire y penser toujours n'en
parler jamais donc ce qui me gêne
beaucoup si vous voulez ce qui fait que
moi je suis de ceux qui n'ont vraiment
aucune hostilité bien au contraire au
mariage entre personnes du même sexe
mais il me semble que si j'accepte à la
fois le mariage et l'adoption
inéluctablement selon effectivement des
des autorités en matière juridique de
tendances différentes je serai amené à
accepter la pma la gpa par simple
convenance c'est à dire une certaine
forme de marchandisation des corps que
je refuse alors comment peut-on faire
mesdames les ministres pour que cet
engrenage de se mettre en route pour
répondre à votre question sur
l'engrenage il y à des traitements
différenciés entre l'assistance médicale
à la procréation et la gestation pour
autrui
à partir du moment où la gestation pour
autrui c'est la position du gouvernement
très clair très ferme demeure un
principe de l'indisponibilité du corps
et d'ordre public
c'est le barrage à l'engrenage c'est le
barrage à l'engrenage
mes chers collègues nous en sommes
arrivés à notre dernière audition
publique et je dois vous dire que le
cette dernière audition est l'occasion
pour moi de redire combien nous avons
pris plaisir à toutes ses auditions en
tout cas plaisir intellectuel et combien
ces auditions nous ont apporté au terme
des auditions
le collectif la manif pour tous menée
par frigide barjot demande à être
entendu à son tour mais j'obtiens michel
refuse de les recevoir
ça fait quarante heures d'audition qu'un
mine aujourd'hui on est plus grande chez
nous pour les entendre la deuxième
raison c'est une raison de fond fait que
je considère que cette pseudo
association créée de toutes pièces pour
les besoins de la cause
noren apporter aux auditions caen puis
se passent très sérieuse et que donc je
n'ai pas souhaité l'entendre voilà au
surpluss dois dire que les
manifestations que ce collectif organisé
me laisse beaucoup à désirer
choqués d'un certain nombre de termes
qui ont été employés par cette pièce
d'homophobie attentes qui ne veut pas
dire son nom mais qui existent pour
motiver son refus jean pierre michel
écrit une lettre au collectif la manif
pour tous aux yeux du sénateur frigide
barjot et le collectif n'ont aucune
légitimité
dans sa lettre il qualifie la manif pour
tous d'homophobe frigide barjot décide
alors d'assigner jean pierre michel en
diffamation aussi monsieur michel
n'avait pas envoyé cette lettre
infamante voilà et diffamatoires eh ben
on ne serait pas là si monsieur hollande
et son gouvernement n'avait pas imposer
cette loi excessive
nous ne serions pas dans l'armée
frigide barjot et la manif pour tous
réclament 6000 euros de dommages
intérêts finalement le tribunal déboute
les requérants
pendant ce temps au sénat avant l'examen
en séance publique la commission des
lois examine le rapport de jean pierre
michel le texte est adopté avec deux
voix de l'opposition
ce débat il n'a pas été un débat et où
les gens ont voté seulement par rapport
à leur appartenance à un parti
ce n'est pas un secret que deux élus de
l'ump ont voté pour le texte et que deux
élus de radicaux de gauche n'ont pas
pris part au vote
il ya une évolution des moeurs qu'on le
veuille ou pas et vous savez un
magistrat au magistrat un jour il cette
phrase que j'ai retenu la meilleure loi
est celle qui entérine l'évolution des
moeurs
on peut pas aujourd'hui accepté de dire
rien ne s'est passé
on est obligé de l'accepter et donc il
faut que la loi salah et en plus la
france n'est pas seule dans le monde et
elle est obligée de tenir quant au
talent est pas obligé de faire pareil
mais elle ne peut pas ne pas en tenir
compte
mais la mobilisation des opposants au
projet de loi ne faiblit pas dans les
yvelines
julien et cécile se prépare pour une
nouvelle manifestation
cette fois ils emmènent leurs trois
garçons pour les vans ou soigneux des
gens qui n'ont pas le goût d'un coeur
ce qu'ils ont payé un aller-retour
l'homosexualité pour moi n'est pas le
n'est pas forcément fait l'enjeu du
débat en fait je pense que
l'homosexualité c'est entre guillemets
ainsi je peux dire c'est l'arbre qui
cache la forêt en fait je pense que tout
le débat qui en qui est en jeu dans ce
projet de loi c'est tout ce qui concerne
la filiation là j'étais à la pma et que
pour pour empêcher le débat pour dire
non enfin on peut on utilise le terme
homophobie comme on utilise le terme
racisme en fait c'est parce que en fait
ça va dans les deux sens dès que peint
voilà donc on utilise le terme
homophobie a comme ça on parle pas
surtout on ne réfléchit pas on utilise
des termes gpa pma que beaucoup de
français ne comprennent pas parce qu'il
voit pas très bien ce que ça veut dire
et je pense que c'est voilà c'est une
façon de nier le débat et pour moi c'est
vraiment une négation de la démocratie
j'ai mon groupe et diane tient et dans
mon groupe va y avoir le sous-groupe
corps si on inscrit quinze personnes
mais on sait pas encore si c'est non
mais propose à thomas grande armée
la cour d'appel
montréal champions
majeur de la civilisation prochaine de
déficit et pour la société française
pourtant à en croire que ce procès ce
qui vit pour autoriser un mariage on va
pouvoir bouleverser toute la filiation
et la catastrophe on a nos petit enfants
qui vont qui vont la vivre
finalement c'est sûr ne sais pas
maintenant s'arrachant d'accès dans les
années futures
ce jour là l'opposition se radicalise la
manifestation va se terminer par des
affrontements avec les forces de l'ordre
et des gaz lacrymogènes
le collectif la manif pour tous va se
laisser déborder par des éléments plus
radicaux
la contestation se durcit les agressions
homophobes se multiplient et le sénat
entame l'examen du texte jean pierre
michel reste serein et déterminé je suis
en état d'esprit de me dire ouf enfin
quoi voilà on est au ban de la
commission je ferme mon rapport et puis
après un énième avant s'est déroulé
pendant quelques jours au sénat et je
suis très heureux d'arriver à ce stade
de la procédure j'allais dire voilà
la soeur s'est reprise l'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion du projet de loi
adopté par l'assemblée nationale ouvrant
le mariage aux couples de personnes de
même sexe et dans la discussion générale
la parole est à madame christiane
taubira garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice et la garde des sceaux qui vient
défendre le texte du gouvernement devant
les sénateurs
comme à son habitude elle va prononcer
un discours sans note pendant 40 minutes
cette institution du mariage qui a été
une institution de propriété autant on
alliès sur tous les patrimoines qui a
été à une institution de domination du
temps où la loi ordonné obéissance à
l'épousé qui a été une institution de
possession du mari sur les phases sur la
femme et sur les enfants qui a été une
institution d'exclusion d'exclusion sur
la base de la religion d'exclusion sur
la base de la profession d'exclusion sur
la base des non croyance cette
institution est en train de devenir
universel sur ce projet de loi nous
avons peu de points d'accord mais nous
en avons un
il n'est pas anecdotique il est même
essentiel et comme vous l'avez si bien
indiqué cette réforme est vraiment une
réforme de civilisation c'est aussi ce
point de consensus ou me le pardonnerai
qui va finalement nous opposer de toute
la force de nos convictions et elles ne
sont pas tiède ni les vôtres ni les
nôtres nous partageons c'est vrai cette
idée qu avec ce texte il y à un
basculement vous soutenez que c'est un
progrès nous pensons que c'est un recul
vous avez commencé par rappeler un
argument qui a été beaucoup utilisé puis
il a fini par tomber un peu d'ici
l'étude j'allais dire à l'assemblée
nationale aussi sur la réforme de
civilisation je me réfère à la
civilisation au sens où aimé césaire
indique qu'une civilisation qui ruse
avec ses principes est une civilisation
moribonde et je reprends donc cette
définition la france
oui la france s'est construite a
construit la nation la république c'est
république sur la passion de l'égalité
sur la passion de l'égalité
et oui nous nous réclamons de légalité
parce que c'est une valeur fondamentale
de la république et que ses lamas
particulière de l'histoire de la nation
française et de l'histoire des
république française
oui oui nous nous référons à cette
égalité est parce que nous nous référons
à cette valeur nous constatons qu
effectivement à diverses périodes il y
as or use avec l'égalité il y a des
prétextes qu'on n'a pas fait inscrire
dans le droit pour refuser à des
citoyens la plénitude de l'exercice de
leur citoyenneté et c'est ça que nous
corrigions nous sommes les citoyens
français de nous représentons médiatique
qui préfèrent que
gouvernement s'occupe des problèmes de
ce pays voilà on arrive à toute vitesse
c'est qu'elle va comprendre comme ça
alors que le sénat va entrer dans le vif
du sujet les pros et les antis font
monter la pression aux abords du palais
du luxembourg
nous aurons la mémoire longue
rené garde parce que nous dressons la
liste de tous ceux qui auront été les
complices de ce projet de loi
quotidiennement pendant sept jours
les opposants vont manifester aux portes
du sénat requise un crayon pour que les
sénateurs qui vont devoir se prononcer
dans les jours qui viennent et bien
comprennent la gravité de la décision du
vote qu'ils prendront et bien nous
demandons au bon dieu nous demandons à
la très sainte vierge marie de bien
vouloir orienter le choix pour le seul
qui soit bon c'est à dire contre le
projet du mariage homosexuel
tu vas bien vous n'aurez pas non sens on
ne sait où on est sans illusion sur le
fond des choses je crois que il y a un
vrai risque ici et c'est une autre forme
de violence que de changer le sens des
mots vous changer d'abord le sens des
mots sur le plan sémantique dans le
français aujourd'hui selon l'académie
française le mariage est l'union
légitime d'un homme et d'une femme vous
changer les mots le sens des mots je
veux redire que toutes les sciences
humaines et sociales montre bien entendu
le contraire et y compris l'académie
française elle même parce que si les
mots n'avaient aucun sens et que ce sens
était immuable
ce serait contraire à l'histoire des
langues à l'histoire tout court vous
savez que le dictionnaire de l'académie
française le plus récent monsieur le
premier ministre c'est le 9e le premier
date de 1694
si on a fait 9 dictionnaire de
l'académie française c'est que le sens
de beaucoup de mots a changé les mots
sont des êtres vivants oui c'est une
guerre de tranchées dans la mesure où
c'est un texte qui engage aux
convictions c'est un texte qui engage
beaucoup plus que ce que nous sommes
parce que et je crois que c'est aussi le
message qu'ont délivrer les millions de
français qui ont défilé depuis des mois
et des mois
ce n'est pas un texte sur lequel nous
battons pour des droits des trois à qui
on se bat aussi pour les français de
demain c'est-à-dire pour les nouvelles
générations je suis favorable à ce texte
parce que je considère que moins l'état
l'examen de la loi se poursuit avec
l'adoption de l'article 1er qui institue
que le mariage est ouvert aux couples de
même sexe
les sénateurs de l'ump ont longtemps
bataillé pour plutôt offrir une union
civile aux couples homosexuels
un amendement présenté par le doyen
gélard qui est finalement rejetée d'un
revers de la main
la pression monte les quelques élus de
droite qui ont déclaré publiquement voté
en faveur du texte reçoivent des
insultes et des lettres anonymes
certains sont même dérangé chez eux au
petit matin c'est pas la violence qui
détermine un vote sont des valeurs et
des convictions et que le débat il se
fait ici donc qui manifestent ici c'est
normal les institutions démocratiques
c'est ici mais quand justement on se
réclame de la défense des droits de la
famille il faut éviter de la violer jean
pierre michel
elle lui aussi la cible des opposants au
mariage homosexuel chaque jour il reçoit
des dizaines de courriers aujourd'hui on
doit être un millier de carte postale
affranchie
donc c'est très bien ça donne des
revenus à la poste qui me sont envoyés
et qui me décerne le prix staline 2013
de l'intolérance
voilà donc c'est un honneur ligne mais
voilà on dit que j'ai dit que l'ipad
naturel parce que je pense que la loi
c'était rapport de force à certain
moment donné on le voit et des majorités
parlementaires qui se crée qui font une
loi après ça quelques fois la loi et est
annulé des fêtes pas tout ça arrive et
que ya un rapport de force politique à
un certain moment donné et que ce
rapport de force
eh bien il en sort eu droit y compris
dans la société y compris
jamais
non
il y aurait les rétrogrades d'un côté
les progressistes de l'hôte
vous avez d'un côté l'idée d'une famille
idéale d'une famille idéale un papa une
maman deux enfants j'ai envie de vous
dire d'abord est ce que cette famille
idéale à exister une seule fois dans
l'histoire est ensuite même si cette
famille idéal existe aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la société est faite que ça
vous plaise que ça vous plaise pas et
que ça me plaise que ça ne me plaisent
pas et fait d'une diversité des formes
de famille et que vous pouvez opposé
effectivement une famille idéale et que
moi j'ai envie de vous opposer la
diversité des familles réelles
existantes aujourd'hui jean-pierre
michel profite d'une suspension de
séance pour aller à la rencontre des
partisans du projet de loi
il est accueilli en héros
et vous êtes en train de changer la vie
des bocks d'opportunités non mais
franchement je veux je veux remercier
énormément et il ya madame taubira et le
gouvernement etc
et merci merci mais le vieux roi pour
comprendre
on va terminer le plein ce soir
dernier amendement dans l'hémicycle la
pression des antilles ne se relâche pas
jusque tard dans la nuit
ils continuent à manifester leur
opposition devant les grilles du palais
du luxembourg
tomber ces images
le président de la république doit
entendre le peuple français
indépendamment des institutions du
parlement qui sur ce sujet ne
représentent pas l'opinion des français
voilà
le chers collègues je mets aux voix
l'ensemble du projet de loi ouvrant le
mariage aux couples de personnes de même
sexe ceux qui sont favorables pour
l'adopter lève la main merci ceux qui
sont contre
merci abstentions
mes chers collègues le sénat a adopté le
projet de loi ouvrant le mariage aux
couples de personnes de même sexe
finalement après sept jours de débats le
sénat vote le texte à main levée le jeu
aucun groupe politique n'ayant demandé
un scrutin public
la loi est adopté par 171 voix contre
165 morts y compris ceux du gouvernement
pour la qualité de vos interventions
pour un débat qui je le crois au nord le
sénat si monsieur le rapporteur de la
commission des lois
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues
bien sûr vous le comprendrez vous avec
beaucoup de fierté et d'émotion que je
savoure ce moment 15 ans après
l'adoption du pacs de faire en sorte que
je participe à une histoire qui n'est
pas fini vous l'avez dit non l'histoire
n'est pas finie elle se poursuivra par
des améliorations constantes
parce que c'est ça notre société nous
ouvrons l'institution républicaine du
mariage aux couples de même sexe
la force et la puissance de la loi
consiste à énoncer des règles générales
qui puisse couvrir toute la diversité
des situations et anticiper sur la
complexité des litiges et nous savons à
quel point l'imagination des hommes et
des femmes est infinie pour compliquer
les litiges notamment parce que en cas
de séparation
en cas de conflit le juge interviendra
le juge interviendra pour protéger le
membre du couple ou de la famille le
plus vulnérable plus fragiles il
interviendra pour veiller à l'intérêt
des enfants et je parle d'enfants oui je
parle d'enfants mais d'enfants d'enfants
qui vivent et qui existent de ses
enfants qui sont dans ces familles de
ces enfants qui sont faits de chair d'os
qui t'ont sont tous vivants de cris de
rire de ses enfants qui s'y colle au
genou de ses enfants qui aiment les
sucreries qui déteste les brocolis de
ses enfants qui nous explose la tête de
ces enfants là ce sont eux que vous
protéger avec ce texte de loi
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que même
des batailles on sait qu'on a le cuir
tanné
on sait qu'on résiste à des tas de
choses et puis on est quand même
submergé par l'émotion donc ça rappelle
simplement que ce que nous faisons à la
loi concernent des personnes voilà face
à la radicalisation des opposants le
gouvernement décide d'accélérer le
rythme le texte est inscrit à l'ordre du
jour de l'assemblée nationale dès la
semaine suivante
la loi est adopté conforme c'est-à-dire
sans modification par les députés le 23
avril 2013
la procédure parlementaire arrive à son
terme
mon 331 coffre
après
après 136 heures et 46 minutes de débats
l'assemblée nationale a adopté le projet
de loi ouvrant le mariage aux couples de
personnes de même sexe
nous avons reconnu les droits de nos
concitoyens dont la citoyenneté
sournoisement contesté et nous avons
ouvert des droits à tous les autres
couples c'est donc incontestablement un
texte généreux que vous avez voté
aujourd'hui et nous en savons
définitivement gré mais l'opposition
n'entend pas en rester là
elle saisit le conseil constitutionnel
pour tenter d'invalider le texte
finalement les sages de la rue de
montpensier donnent leur feu vert
la loi est promulguée dans la foulée par
le président de la république quelques
jours plus tard à montpellier bruno et
vincent se disent oui devant les caméras
du monde entier
pourquoi nous est uni
la france devient le quatorzième pays au
monde à autoriser le mariage homosexuel
où